the movie starts in 1984 when Flight
jl50 is taking off from Kolkata however
halfway through the flight they start
experiencing heavy turbulence and bad
weather suddenly the communications are
cut off and the plane is Lost Without a
Trace
from that day on not a single clue is
found regarding The Disappearance the
movie then cuts to 35 years later in the
year 2019 we are shown a remote Village
in West Bengal named lava where a bunch
of kids are playing football suddenly a
large plane flies over them which is
very rare in a hilly area like theirs
the group immediately rushes in the
direction of the plane and finds out
that it is crashed into the nearby Hills
the scene then shifts to Kolkata city
where the protagonist chantanu is
watching a news report on TV the report
mentions that a commercial airplane
flight ao26 which had several
high-profile people on board has gone
missing it is suspected that the plane
has been hijacked a while later shantanu
heads to his workplace the Central
Bureau of Investigation it turns out
that he is a high-ranking officer there
he then goes to the crash site with his
colleague garanga and starts his
investigation at first he approaches a
rescue Soldier and inquires about their
progress the soldier reveals that all
but two people died in the crash and the
survivors of receiving medical attention
one of the survivors is the pilot and
the other one is a passenger this
strange thing is that a passenger's
corpse is found in the cockpit
indicating that the plane was hijacked
before it crashed after the conversation
the three prepared aboard a helicopter
to visit the crash site but just then
the soldier remembers something very
important he tells the CBI officers that
the crashed plane is not the one they're
looking for in simple words it is not
flight ao26 it is in fact flight JL 50
that disappeared 35 years ago the movie
then flashes to the past to the year
1984 and we are introduced to an
aspiring pilot from Kolkata bihu she has
everything one could ask for a
high-paying job a loving family and a
bright future however for some reason
she is upset from the past few months
her mother tells her to brighten up and
forget the past but bihu simply ignores
her and leaves back in the present bee
who is fighting for her life in the
hospital she is none other than the
pilot of the crashed flight jl50 which
went missing in 1984 meanwhile shantanu
and garenga traveled to another remote
Village and visit a school there they
summon the physics Professor Dr subroto
Das and start interrogating him shantani
reveals that the crashed plane jl50 had
departed for its destination in 1984 and
disappeared Without a Trace he also
tells the old man that one of the seats
in the flight was vacant and the ticket
belonged to none other than Das himself
for a brief moment Doss is visibly
stunned as this is some Final
Destination [ __ ] but he claims that he
doesn't remember about the past as he
has become old now Dr Doss then heads
home and starts searching for something
a few moments later he collects a bunch
of documents some pictures and burns
them all together this implies that he
knows something about the plane crash
later a news report reveals that a
terrorist organization named the ABA has
claimed responsibility for flight ao26's
hijacking and is demanding the release
of their leader partho majumder in
exchange for the passenger's safety
partho is scheduled to be executed in a
few days it is also reported that the
officials will surrender to their
demands a few days later pilot bihu
regains Consciousness and santanu heads
over to interrogate her first and
foremost he asks her how the plane
crashed and bihu starts narrating
everything she reveals that like any
other day the flight took off at 3 pm
for the first 10 minutes everything was
fine but suddenly a passenger barged
into the cockpit and stabbed the
co-pilot to death the in-flight meals
must have been terrible he then gave
bihu some coordinates and threatened her
to alter the plane's root but before she
could comply the weather deteriorated
all of a sudden this caused the plane to
go through an intense session of
turbulence and soon it crashed after the
story centeno asks bihu the location and
date of the flights take off and the
latter replies Kolkata 1984. as expected
shantanu doesn't believe her words and
calls her a liar he then mentions that
there in 2019 and hearing this bihu has
taken him back to find out more about
her the CBI officers reached bihu's old
house and enter interrogate some of the
neighbors nearby since the incident
happened 35 years ago not many people
know her but fortunately they come
across a couple who were close to bihu's
family the husband reveals that bihu was
a skilled pilot but her career started
going downhill when she got into a
relationship with a man he made her
pregnant before marriage and passed away
mysteriously however bihu's Breaking
Point came when her child was born dead
soon the husband takes out a photo album
and shows a picture of bihu right before
she was killed in 1984 lo and behold she
looks exactly like the bihu in the
hospital despite the evidence santanu
who doesn't believe in time travel still
thinks that everything is fabricated
later he heads back to the CBI base and
listens to the Black Box recording of
jl50 as bihu had mentioned previously
some hijackers entered the cockpit and
killed the co-pilot then after a while
everything went silent sontanu asks his
technician the last date the Black Box
recorded anything and the latter
mentions August 23rd 1984. this comes as
a surprise to everyone as a black box is
virtually indestructible hence they
adamantly have to believe that the plane
has somehow traveled through time to the
year 2019 meanwhile the second Survivor
from the jl50 Flight crash Mitra has
regained Consciousness when a nurse
informs him that the crash has another
Survivor Mitra immediately heads to
bihu's room to finish her off luckily a
nurse notices him and calls for help
however instead of surrendering The
Lunatic Mitra holds the nurse at knife
point and emerges in the hospital's
hallway santanu also arrives at the same
time and tries to calm Mitra down but
the latter doesn't listen instead he
slowly approaches the main door and when
everyone is expecting it the least he
escapes santanu runs after the lunatic
but by the time he reaches downstairs
Mitra has already escaped in a car
suspicious santani then conducts
research on him he finds out that Mitra
was a genius who is a professor at the
Kolkata science research center he was
also a left-wing activist who was
involved with some terrorist
organizations 35 years ago after finding
Mitra address santani reaches his home
there he finds a huge collection of
books files and other research papers
that Mitra had written in his lifetime
santanu opens one of the files and comes
across a research paper named project a
when he flips over some pages he also
finds the blueprint of the jl50 flight
realizing that it is related to the
plane crash he decides to take the file
with him later in order to find out more
about Mitra and his project a sontanu
goes to the Kolkata science research
center and talks to a professor named
Ashwini as soon as Ashwini hears about
the project he starts giving a history
lesson he mentions that in 253 BC the
Emperor of India gathered Scholars
scientists and philosophers from all
around the country who produce nine
different books which taught about
several Supernatural Arts like
invisibility the ability to fly and time
travel these books were then buried into
the ground fearing that the enemies
might use it for their personal use
several Millennia later some pages of
the time travel book were found and a
team of researchers was put together to
prove the theory this top secret
research program was labeled project a
but no conclusion ever came from it
after hearing this story santanu
inquires about Mitra but Ashwini
mentions that he doesn't know much about
him instead He suggests santanu meet Dr
Doss claiming that the two were very
close back then at night an enraged
santanu barges into doss's house and
confronts him for lying earlier he then
brings out the project a papers and
tells dos to reveal everything left with
no choice the old man starts speaking he
says that mitra's father was a part of
project a but when they couldn't find
any conclusion the government pulled the
plug on it years later Mitra continued
his father's research and after working
day and night he finally found the code
once again santani doesn't believe in
the story and calls it BS but dos tells
him that everything is true he continues
by saying that Mitra using his genius
mind researched the incomplete project
day papers and found the formula with
the help of which he discovered some
wormholes in the Earth's atmosphere
through these wormholes time travel is
possible Doss further mentions that he
was mitra's disciple at the time so he
knew the entire plan Mitra wanted to
hijack a plane fly it Through the
Wormhole and reach another timeline for
this he formed an alliance with
parthomajumber who is the terrorist
leader that caused plane ao26 to be
hijacked in the present time at last dos
concludes by saying that he didn't board
the flight because he became scared he
sensed that the experiment would go
wrong and so it did Mitra had hoped to
return back with the flight in 35 hours
but his calculations turned out to be
wrong and the plane vanished for 35
years getting math wrong in that way
makes no sense surprisingly even after
all this explanation sontano refuses to
believe a word but thus reminds him that
the officials have finally agreed to
release the terrorist leader partho from
custody in two days if he and Mitra
reunite they can use their knowledge and
power to cause some serious damage to
the country I don't know though Mitra
seems like an idiot this time santanu
appears to be concerned so Das tells him
that there is a way to stop Mitra he
proposes that they enter the Wormhole
and go back in time to 1984 where they
can stop jl50 from being hijacked if
they succeed there will be no deaths and
criminals like partho and organizations
like ABA will never exist although still
hesitant centano agrees in the following
scene the duo heads to meet bihu at the
hospital as she is the only one who
knows the coordinates to the Wormhole
santani requests her for the information
but bihu who is still shocked that she
has traveled 35 years into the future
doesn't want to comply so easily after a
lot of convincing she agrees but only if
she is permitted to fly the plane
sontanu clearly doesn't want to give in
to her demands but since this is a top
secret mission and since she is the only
pilot anyway he has no choice but to
agree the next morning garanga arranges
an airplane secretly and the trio sets
off on their mission suntanu still
thinks that everything's a joke but as
they are about to reach the supposed
Wormhole everything starts shaking
suddenly the plane malfunctions and bihu
is forced to make an emergency landing
in open field the area seems completely
different from the one they just laughed
soon a vintage car arrives and the three
ask for a lift and get in after a while
they reach Kolkata City and santanu
finally realizes that they have actually
arrived in 1984. the streets buses
hotels and the people everything
resembles the 80s although santanu is
taken aback by the weird situation he
decides to finish off what they came for
but at first he wants to grow a mustache
I mean he wants to get something off his
chest at night he heads to an orphanage
and here it is revealed that santanu is
an orphan who is dropped off at the same
orphanage in the year 1984. he waits for
a while and suddenly two men arrive in a
car and drop the baby inside santanu
rushes inside to check if the baby is
him from the past and from a locket he
verifies his assumption I suspended
disbelief for the time travel thing but
The Coincidence of this timing is
absolutely ridiculous the next morning
he joins Das and bihu and the three
start discussing their next step Das who
is a close confidante to Mitra in the
the past reveals that the secret meeting
on the jl50 hijacking is going to take
place this evening in a warehouse
outside town later the group reaches the
said place and waits for the
perpetrators to arrive while inside the
car santanu curiously asks bihu if she
saw her stillborn child with her own
eyes but the latter has no answer for
this bihu simply says that after the
delivery she became unconscious and when
she woke up the next day her parents
gave her the bad news that her baby was
born dead meanwhile Mitra partho and
other thugs arrive at the warehouse and
the meeting commences hence the three
make a plan Dawson santani will be
confronting the thugs inside while bihu
will be waiting in the car according to
the plan the two head inside and point
their guns at Mitra and his men but just
then the goons also Strike Back
initiating a deadly shootout fortunately
santanu uses his Superior combat skills
and takes down the thugs one by one in
the end he also takes down partho while
Dr dos kills his former Mentor Mitra now
with the mission accomplished santanu
grabs the suitcase containing project a
papers and tries to burn it but
surprisingly dos holds him at gunpoint
and threatens for him to stand back here
it is revealed that everything was das's
plan all along since the original
project they papers were burnt to ashes
in the JL 50 crash the exact coordinates
for the time travel wormholes were lost
however dos was not ready to give up so
easily so when santanu approached him
for interrogation an idea struck his
mind he decided to use the CBI officer
to travel back in time and steal the
papers with the help of which he could
gain immortality what dos also reveals
that the day Mitra escaped from the
hospital he arrived at his house but
instead of helping dos killed him hence
removing a major obstacle from his path
with this Revelation the two shoot at
each other but dos comes off of it the
worst allowing santanu to destroy the
papers once and for all he then proceeds
to leave with bihu but suddenly all
three of them begin experiencing an
excruciating painful sound it turns out
that since Mitra and his men were killed
the plain jl50 never Got Hijacked and
hence the three never traveled to the
past now the timeline is rejecting
unwanted anomalies and hence the
three-year-old teleported back to the
present however a small change in the
past results in a completely different
and Alternate future in the final scene
santanu is shown traveling in ao26 with
his wife and their plane is not hijacked
in fact both flight ao26 and jl50 were
never hijacked as the villains were
killed back in 1984. shantanu and
garango even run into each other in the
plane but do not recognize each other
this means that the two never became
friends in this alternate reality and
probably shantanu did not even get to
join the CBI as an officer santani then
arrives at the same orphanage to
celebrate his birthday as he is playing
with the kids and all the bee who
approaches him and hugs him tightly in a
shocking turn of events it is revealed
that bihu's son was not born dead after
all in fact the child was dropped to the
orphanage by bihu's father as it was
born before bihu was married and he
feared that the society wouldn't accept
accept her the child is none other than
santanu himself however in the new
timeline after the jl50 flight returned
safely bihu's mother eventually told her
the truth and that's how the mother-son
Duo were reunited now in this timeline
the two have never been apart the movie
ends as santanu and his mother
distribute presence to the orphan kids
and play with them as both are
empathetic happy and grateful for their
new lives subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching